[Music]
making big decisions can be hard even
after considering all the options doing
research and selecting what you think is
the best solution there's always a fear
that you chose wrong
to lessen that fear a lot of us seek out
advice from friends or even strangers on
the internet in the belief that two or
better yet many minds are better than
just one this kind of decision making is
a lot like having a hive mind where a
large number of individuals share their
knowledge with each other which produces
a collective intelligence
this often leads to smarter decision
making among groups that is better than
what one individual could accomplish
alone while often used in science
fiction stories hive minds actually do
exist in real life there are lots of
great examples of this in nature but one
stands out and it comes from the animal
that inspired the phrase hive mind in
the first place bees these insects use
nest-based communication to give their
fellow bees important information and
collectively make robust decisions
but their methods of communication
aren't what you might expect they
communicate via dance and their dances
can communicate to their peers the
direction distance and quality of food
sources the location of possible new
hive sites and sources of nearby danger
and most surprisingly they can even use
their language to hold democratic
debates this type of collective behavior
is so powerful and the connection
between the bees is so profound that
scientists are beginning to understand
that a bee colony acts a lot like a
single organism
in fact a lot like a human brain
and studying how these remarkable
creatures interact could reveal answers
about how our own minds make decisions
although only about 10 percent of bee
species are social honeybees are very
social indeed apis mellifera or the
western honeybee is the most common of
the 12 or so honey bee species they
create large colonies with a single
fertile queen many non-reproductive
female workers and a small number of
fertile males individual colonies can
house tens of thousands of bees and all
of the activity carried out by these
bees is organized by complex
communication between individuals
in the early 1900s scientists believed
that bees might communicate the presence
of nearby food sources through scent
the fragrance of the flower adhering to
the bees bodies and alerting its peers
of its nearby presence
by this theory the other bees should
simply search in an ever-expanding
circle until they discover the flowers
with the memorized fragrance but in 1944
carl von frisch a professor at the
university of munich made a discovery
that turned this assumption on its head
a discovery that would eventually win
him the nobel prize
von frisch noticed that after observing
the returning scout bee the other worker
bees did not search for flowers with a
matching scent everywhere around the
hive but only in the precise vicinity of
where the foraging bee had been even if
that bee had been very far away somehow
the exact location of the food source
was being communicated by the bees
when von frisch observed his bees more
closely he discovered that bees are
constantly waggling running and turning
in circles inside the hive he then
realized that this performance is a
miniature re-enactment of the bee's
recent flight outside the hive
indicating the location of the food
source it just visited von frisch had
just discovered communication via dance
and with it foragers can share
information about the direction and
distance to the patches of flowers full
of nectar and pollen with other members
of the colony their dance is called the
waggle dance and its main feature is the
waggle run where they waggle back and
forth while running in a straight line
the duration of the run tells the other
bees how far the resource is where one
second is equal to about a thousand
meters and the angle of their run
relative to a straight vertical line
tells the other bees the angle of the
outward journey in relation to the sun
for example if the dancing bee walks 45
degrees to the right of the vertical
line the food source is 45 degrees to
the right of the position of the sun in
addition to dancing the bee also gives
out some of the flowers nectar to its
audience which combined with the smell
of the flower still lingering on the
dancing bee helps the recruits locate
the food source they communicate other
things through dance as well for
instance a tremble dance where they rock
forward and backward and side to side
tells others that the foragers have
brought back so much nectar that more
bees are needed to process it into honey
but not every bee conversation is about
food sources and not every piece of
communication is a one-way street one be
communicating something to the rest bees
can use these same communication methods
to discuss options about the future of
the hive and then make decisions
democratically a type of collective
behavior very rarely seen in the animal
kingdom
[Music]
in late spring or early summer honeybee
colonies become overcrowded in their
nesting cavities when this happens it's
time for them to find a new home
one third of the worker bees stay put
and rear a new queen and two-thirds of
the workers along with the original
queen begin the search for a new nest
site the quest starts with the swarm
congregating on a temporary site a
branch or a bush outside the old hive
from here scouts will go out and look
for suitable nest sites a hollowed-out
tree or an abandoned chimney or
birdhouse
the bees are looking for a place that
will be protected from weather predators
and is big enough for the new hive
size is perhaps the most important since
any colony occupying a hollow 10 liters
or smaller can't store enough honey to
make it through the winter once a bee
finds a location that it likes it comes
back to the group and does the waggle
dance telling the others where the
potential nest site is other bees then
go check it out for themselves if these
recruits like it they'll come back and
do the same dance in the same direction
but it's not always so clear which
potential nest site is the best choice
and this is where a vigorous debate
begins here's an example of how these
debates typically go down taken from one
of the first studies about bee debates
in 1951
on the first day two nest scout bees
were identified and labeled one b
reported a nest site candidate 1500
meters to the north while the other bee
reported another site 300 meters to the
southeast the next day 11 new dancers
were identified three danced in support
of the site 1500 meters to the north two
danced in support of the site 300 meters
to the southeast and six others danced
about new sites altogether the next day
it rained and only two new dancers were
recorded one supported the site to the
north and the other reported a new site
400 meters to the southwest the next day
many new sites were reported but
interestingly the site to the north was
no longer being supported perhaps
because rain leaked into the site
showing it was not such a good candidate
after all over the next few days many
sites were investigated and reported but
interest in most of them eventually
faded only one site the one located 300
meters to the southeast held the bees
interest the entire time by the
afternoon of the fourth day the bees
dancing in support of the southeast site
completely dominated with 61 bees
dancing for it and only two bees holding
out for other sites the next morning the
decision was unanimous the swarm then
launched into flight flew 300 meters to
the southeast and took up residence in
the wall of an abandoned building by
analyzing bee debates like this the key
features of the bee's decision-making
process becomes clear the debate first
starts with an information gathering
phase where many alternatives are put on
the table for discussion the debate then
progresses with all or almost all the
bees advocating for just one site
indicating that a consensus has been
reached and during all of this the
process is highly distributed involving
dozens or even hundreds of individuals
all the hallmarks of a democratic
process the dances they perform are
complex and indicate a lot of cognitive
ability the bees have to remember the
location of the resource or the nest
site as well as the location of the sun
and translate that information into the
characteristics of the dance the bees in
the audience then have to read this
behavior and translate it into the
direction that they will then follow
this along with the coordinated decision
to fly off in the same direction at the
same time supports the idea that a bee
swarm acts as if it's one organism a
super organism and recently scientists
have realized it's even more profound
than that the way bees work together is
a lot like how the individual neurons in
the human brain work together and
studying their behavior may give insight
into our own minds
psychophysical laws explain the relation
between real-world stimuli and the
perception of those stimuli the brains
of many organisms follow these laws even
quite simple ones
weber's law states that the change in a
stimulus that will be just noticeable is
a constant ratio of the original
stimulus for example it might take four
pounds before you notice your backpack
getting heavier if your backpack was
already loaded with heavy books hicks
law says that the brain is slower to
make decisions when the number of
alternative options increases and
pieron's law says that the brain is
quicker to make decisions when the
options to decide from are of high
quality these laws help relate the
brain's perception of reality to actual
reality and are important when making
decisions many organisms adhere to these
laws even simple animals like fish or
insects fish for example can
differentiate between a large school of
fish and a small one opting to join the
larger one as long as the size
difference was large enough for them to
be able to recognize it but do these
laws only explain an individual's brain
and behavior could these laws also apply
to an entire colony of bees as one unit
in 2018 scientists started to get their
answer
they analyzed how quickly the colonies
made decisions between sites of varying
qualities and compared the data with
several psychophysical laws to see how
well the laws were adhered to and it
turns out the bee colony followed the
laws closely
it followed weber's law and that the
bees were able to choose the higher
quality nest site if and when the higher
quality such as a larger size exceeded
the minimum noticeable difference they
also found that the bee colony was
slower to make decisions when the number
of alternative nest sites increased and
that the colony was quicker to make a
decision between two high-quality nest
sites compared to two low-quality nest
sites honey bee colonies adhere to the
same laws as the brain when making
collective decisions these findings give
more support for the idea that bee
colonies exist as super organisms
operating in the world much like a
single complete organism would and just
as the bee colony is similar to a whole
brain the individual bee thus acts like
a single neuron in the human brain
decisions are made when single nerves
fire waves of electrochemical signals
in bee colonies decisions are made when
individual bees communicate their
discoveries through a visual display to
other bees and if bees follow the same
laws as neurons then observing them can
lead to a better understanding of our
own minds and more quickly too observing
bee colonies is much easier than trying
to observe the neurons of a brain while
a human makes decisions
by understanding these parallels we can
start to learn just how psychophysical
laws work and with more data bees could
teach us how our entire psychology
arises from a few chemical actions from
a few connected cells
and outside understanding our own minds
computer scientists have created lots of
different algorithms based on b's
decision-making methods
one popular decision-making model is the
artificial bee colony or abc algorithm
it's used for optimizing problems where
users are looking for the best possible
solution among many different options
in this model each candidate solution is
like a food source and the quality of
that solution is akin to the amount of
nectar it holds it begins with a number
of employed bees at each of the food
sources
they then go out to neighboring food
sources and compare the amount of nectar
to the previous source they only
remember the information of the best
food source they find after a certain
number of steps they share their
information with onlooker bees who then
choose what they think is the best food
source and the sources that aren't
selected are abandoned
this continues until the best food
source or solution is identified this
algorithm has been used to solve many
real-world engineering problems across a
variety of fields for instance
electrical engineers have used it to
determine the optimal position of solar
panels for when they are in partial
shade aerospace engineers have used it
to plan the re-entry trajectory of
hypersonic vehicles and computer
scientists have used it to plan the path
of robots proving the true power of the
hive mind the intersection of biology
and computer science is an exciting one
as the different ways we can solve real
world problems with solutions that
nature has already made are basically
infinite algorithms are at the heart of
this and while they seem complicated are
easier to wrap your head around than you
might realize
if you've ever been put off by opaque
coding language but really want to learn
how algorithms work or even start making
your own you should sign up for
brilliant brilliant can help you learn
how to program without having to dig
through the weeds of coding syntax
through these fun interactive challenges
you just shift around these blocks of
pseudo code and then you can get
immediate feedback on your results it's
a good way to understand how computer
algorithms work and then once you have
that down the coding syntax becomes a
lot less intimidating i don't have a
computer science background at all but
lately it's become more and more
important for me to understand it when
making these videos as it's a topic that
keeps coming up brilliant's algorithm
fundamentals course has helped me learn
that algorithms really are just a set of
instructions and putting them together
to get the computer to do what you want
is like a really fun puzzle if you'd
like to try out brilliant for free and
get 20 off a year of stem learning click
the link in the description down below
or visit brilliant.org
real science
as always thanks for watching and if
you're looking for something else to
watch right now you can watch our
previous video the insane biology of
dragonflies or real engineering's latest
video that debunks a popular and
mysterious image of airplanes that has
been circulating the internet for years